vamos con el problema 107 problemas 107
nos dicen que un número que en su parte
decimal tiene sólo una cantidad finita
de dígitos distintos de 0 se le llama
terminante terminante
me antes ok estos son un poco complicado
pero afortunadamente creo que dan
ejemplos dice por ejemplo 24 24 0.82
0.82 y 5.096 5.096 son terminantes ok
creo que lo que están pidiendo es que no
ocurra algo del estilo 0.33
es 333 y así sucesivamente vale o sea
que de a de veras se termina en algún
momento va bueno eso es un decimal o un
número terminante ok entonces nos dicen
si r&s son enteros positivos r y s son
enteros enteros positivos
positivos y pasamos la fracción r / s a
decimal a decimal
queda un numero terminante la pregunta
es si queda un numero terminante
terminante
ok entonces vamos a ver qué información
nos dan para ver si podemos responder
esto decentemente en el inciso 1 nos
dicen que el 90 90 es menor que r y eso
es menor que siendo menor que 100 yo
creo que esto no nos dice gran cosa esto
únicamente nos habla del numerador de la
fracción pero el denominador podría
hacer cosas raras por ejemplo si tomamos
cualquier ere de estas no importa cual
tomate si quieres 94 y la dividimos
entre entre 13 r es igual a 13 r
entonces esto nos queda
nos quedaría igual a un tercio esto nos
quedaría un tercio y un tercio no es
terminante porque justo su expansión
decimal es esta de acá vale entonces ahí
tendríamos un ejemplo donde no es
terminante pero si tenemos que ese es
dos veces r tendríamos r entre 12 r que
es igual a un medio que es igual a un
medio que es igual a 0.5 que si es
terminante vale entonces esta
información de aquí no es suficiente
todavía tenemos que
cosas acerca del denominador bueno vamos
al inciso 2 en el inciso 2 lo que nos
dicen es que ese es igual a 4 s es igual
a 4 bueno si dividimos algo entre 4 un
número entero
rc entero entre 4 entonces me parece que
siempre tenemos un decimal terminante a
ver cómo le hacemos para decirlo bueno
supongamos o fijémonos en el residuo que
deja erre al dividirse entre 4 cuando
dividimos entre 4 r puedes dejar residuo
cero
dos o tres si se deja residuos cero eso
quiere decir que es divisible entre
cuatro entonces s / r es entero y por lo
tanto es terminante verdad sí sí dejar
residuos 1 yo digo que es algo con 1.25
punto 25 con residuos 2 es algo con
punto 5 y conocido 13 es algo con punto
75 entonces en cualquiera de estos casos
tenemos que es un decimal terminante y
por lo tanto saber que ese es igual a 4
es suficiente para concluir que r / s es
terminante vale entonces el inciso 2 es
suficiente por sí mismo el inciso 1 no
sirvió de nada entonces la respuesta
sería b
ve muy bien esto de aquí lo puedes
pensar tantito inténtalo con varios
números fíjate en un número cuál es el
residuo que deja al dividirse entre 4
divide lo entre 4 y observa que justo
los decimales quedan esto vale bueno
vamos ahora al problema
108 problema 108 en el problema 108 nos
dibujan un triángulo que voy a dibujar
por aquí entonces tenemos un triángulo
más o menos así así
un poquito más ancho digamos algo así y
así y además nos marcan un punto adentro
y otro triangulito como algo de este
estilo más o menos van
y tenemos nombres de los vértices estoy
aquí se llama a este de acá se llama be
este de acá se llama ce y este de y nos
marcan dos ángulos este de aquí que es
de equis grados y este de acá que es de
grados ok
este es el dibujo voy a leer el problema
el problema dice en esta figura cuál es
el valor de x + entonces nos están
preguntando por x más que x más bueno
vamos a ver qué opciones nos dan en el
inciso 1
nos dicen que x es igual a 70 x es igual
a 70 por supuesto esto no nos va a decir
nada acerca de ella es verdad este punto
d se podría mover pues libremente a
dentro del triángulo aunque esté x fuera
fijo y la lleva cambiando y entonces x
más que tendría diferentes valores y no
podemos decidirnos por uno entonces esta
información por sí misma no es
suficiente
a lo mejor funcione combinándola con el
inciso 2 en el inciso 2 nos dicen que el
triángulo abc abc y el triángulo ads
triángulo adc son isósceles son
isósceles son eles
isósceles ok no podemos asumir nada de
la figura en la figura parece que ave es
igual a veces pero tal vez tenemos que
que ave es igual a hace y tenemos que
ade es igual a hace no sabemos si sólo
sabemos que estos dos son isósceles pero
no sabemos en qué orden están los lados
iguales si éste es igual a este oeste es
igual a éste si éste es igual a éste o
éste es igual a éste bueno vamos a ver
si estas dos y si estos dos pedazos de
información nos permiten determinar el
valor de x más yo digo que yo digo que
no porque en realidad no tenemos todavía
mucha información verdad o sea no
sabemos cuál es el ángulo en nada ni el
ángulo en sí a lo mejor sabemos que éste
se xy éste también es equis pero igual
no sabemos cuánto es x bueno y xc70
pudiéramos calcular este de acá pero a
lo mejor x no es el ángulo que se repite
a lo mejor los que se repiten son estos
entonces realmente no tenemos mucha
información verdad únicamente tenemos
este xy algunos lados iguales entonces
me parece que ni siquiera
estas dos podemos responder la pregunta
y por lo tanto la respuesta sería y
sería y para ser un poco más formales
tendríamos que dar ejemplos concretos
donde se cumplen las dos y el valor de x
mayor puede cambiar pero ahorita no me
voy a meter mucho en esto vale bueno
vamos ahora al problema 109 problema 109
déjame bajar
ahí está bien entonces nos dicen que los
enteros nos preguntan si los enteros
positivos pq son ambos mayores que n
entonces p y q son enteros positivos
enteros positivos
positivos y nos preguntan si ambos son
mayores que en la pregunta es ambos
a ambos
mayores que n
bueno pues vamos a ver qué sucede en el
inciso 1 en el inciso 1 nos dicen qué p
es mayor que n p -
es mayor que en esto de aquí será
suficiente para determinar que ambos le
ganan a n yo tengo que no esto es muy
poquita información por ejemplo a lo
mejor tenemos que n es igual a 2 que p
es igual a 10 y que q es igual a 1 en
este caso p menos q es 9 y 9 le gana a 2
sale y tenemos que pp si le gana n 10 le
gana 2 pero q no le gana pero también
podríamos tener en igualados
p igual a 10 igual a 3 igual a 3 pm
moscú sería 7 que le sigue ganando a 2 a
n y aquí sí tenemos que pq ambos le
ganan a n entonces pues esto es todo
estos ejemplos muestran que sólo este
pedazo de información no nos permite
determinar si los dos se le ganan la
n-va ahora vayamos al inciso 2 en el
inciso 2
nos dicen que q es mayor que p q es
mayor que p esto de aquí no tiene nada
que ver con n entonces definitivamente
sí sí va a servir de algo es para
combinarlo con el inciso 1 vamos a ver
si combinando los dos funciona esa es la
parte interesante verdad a ver entonces
aquí tenemos que que obligan a p
entonces p - q es menor que cero si
puedo pasar restando esta q 0 le gana a
p - p menos q
pero observa aquí nos dicen que n es
menor que p
entonces tenemos que 0 le gana a p
y esto le gana a n de esta forma 0 le
gana a n vaya n es menor que 0 n es
menor que cero y 100 es menor que cero
ya terminamos a ver pues vehículos son
ambos positivos entonces p le gana 0 que
le gana a n
por lo tanto p le gana a n y también
tenemos que q le gana 0 que le gana a n
y entonces q le gana a n entonces si
combinando estos dos pero estos dos
pedazos de información podemos concluir
que ambos tanto p como q le ganan a n
muy bien este problema estuvo muy padre
espero que haya algunos más así seguimos
en el siguiente vídeo valga la
redundancia nos vemos hasta la próxima